ta montre est tombé à la mer tu la vois
avec ton masque tu te dis que c'est pas
foutu tu peux aller la chercher alors tu
plonges sauf qu'au bout de quelques
mètres tu manques d'air des oreilles
hurle de douleur et époux semblent
imploser oui ce jour là ma montre est
resté au fond de l'eau mais est ce que
mon corps de débutant en apnée aurait pu
le faire aujourd'hui je vous propose
d'explorer les limites du corps humain
avec une petite expérience si un jour où
vous jette avec une pierre au milieu de
la fosse mariannes qu'est-ce qui se
passerait pour votre corps à quel point
pouvez vous plonger profond sans mourir
quelle est la profondeur maximale en
apnée quand tu plonges au fond de la
piscine et que tu penses manquer d'air
disons le c'est juste une impression en
fait tu es assez large quand tu vas
avoir la sensation que tes poumons
commence à brûler il te reste
généralement encore assez d'oxygène pour
tenir au moins deux fois plus longtemps
le problème c'est plutôt les déchets tu
le sais ton corps utilise de l'oxygène
qui devient du co2 que tu dois évacuer
en expirant mise en apnée c'est pas
possible et la concentration de co2
augmente dangereusement dans ton sens si
tu n'as pas l'habitude de cette
sensation ton cerveau va finir par
craquer et que j'ai à respirer malgré ta
bonté mais grâce à un entraînement
intense de super sayen tu peut repousser
ce moment le plus loin possible
concrètement le record d'apnée statique
et de 11 minutes et 35 secondes
exactement le temps pour une petite
vidéo science trash paradoxalement à
l'air libre ce temps aurait été
considérablement réduits car s'ils
conservent o te fait paniquer il s'est
aussi parfaitement s'adapter au milieu
aquatique en fait on a un réflexe
préhistorique quand notre tête et dans
l'eau instinctivement notre sens se
concentrent dans les organes vitaux
notre respiration se bloque et notre
rythme cardiaque ralentit c'est un des
super pouvoirs de ton corps que tu dois
utiliser pour aller exploser son record
d'apnée le réflexe d'immersion d'emma
mystère impro peut faire battre son
coeur trois fois moins vite qu'une
personne dans le coma et donc économiser
son oxygène et sa production de co2
deuxième super pouvoirs nécessaires pour
plonger l'érection
quoi pas de ta bistouquette mais bien de
tes poumons un pro de l'apnée va être
capable d'imiter ce que fait un phoque
durcir leurs poumons en l'égorgeant de
sens quand on descend en profondeur la
pression de l'eau va comprimer la cage
thoracique les poumons bond rapetisser
jusqu'à la taille d'une balle de tennis
les gonfler 200 leur permettra d'être
plus résistant à cette pression pour ne
pas être complètement écrasées pour
retrouver ce super pouvoir ancestral il
faut régulièrement exploser son corps
aux pressions des grandes profondeurs
autant dire qu'on observe ce
comportement que chez une poignée de
plongeurs dans le monde la pression de
l'eau peut également provoqué une
perforation des tympans si la pression
de l'eau pousse trop et que la membrane
ne peut plus résister elle va se
déchirer or il se trouve que la nature a
donné un super pouvoir pour gérer ça un
conduit qui relie le tympan à la gorge
c'est la trompe d'eustache par laquelle
on va insuffler de l'air pour regonfler
le tapant c'est ce que font les pros ils
passent leur nez et souffle on appelle
ça la manoeuvre de balsa leva l'idée en
soufflant et d'augmenter la pression de
l'autre côté de la paroisse du tympan de
sorte à empêcher l'eau de forcer le
passage et de tout casser donc voilà si
tu apprenez à bien maîtriser et et trois
supers pouvoirs on pourrait te lâcher en
plein milieu d'un océan de support et
techniquement tenir 11 minutes en
descendant à 1 mètre par seconde tu
pourrait théoriquement atteindre une
profondeur de 660 m 3 fois plus loin que
le plus aventureux des dauphins sont que
c'est pas si simple tout dim est
redescendu c'est comme si l'on t'écraser
d'un kilo supplémentaire et ça va
beaucoup modifier la chimie de ton corps
des poumons vont être comprimées ce qui
va forcer tous l'air qu'ils contiennent
à passer dans ton sens quand la pression
augmente l'oxygène stocker rentre donc
plus vite dans ton corps un peu trop
vite même grâce à ce mini shoot
d'oxygène tu te sens bien voir le foriic
et tu te dis que tu peux prolonger
encore un peu plus son acné cette erreur
va être fatale tu le sais pas encore
mais tu es déjà mort ce danger sournois
a été baptisé le rendez-vous syncopale
17 m car quand tu commences à remonter
c'est à ces sept mètres que la pression
diminue suffisamment pour que la chimie
de ton sang revienne à la normale
l'oxygène qui s'y était dissous de force
grâce à la profondeur ressort alors
comme quand tu ouvre une bouteille d'eau
gazeuse est subitement dansant devient
très pauvre en oxygène tous les voyants
passent au rouge dont cerveau très
sensible au manque d'oxygène panique
dans quelques secondes tu vas perdre
connaissance si tu n'es pas rapidement
remonter c'est la noyade un rendez vous
avec la mort seulement quelques coups de
canne de la surface cette chute brutale
d'oxygène peut même mettre ko un
plongeur quelques secondes après qu'il
ait quand même pu remonter respirer car
le sang réoxygéner n'a pas eu le temps
d'arriver au sort on voit ici un
sauveteur soufflé sur le visage de la
plongeuse pour que son corps comprennent
qu'il est à l'air libre et des actifs
son réflexe d'apnée mais même après
avoir été secouru d'une noyade l'eau qui
s'est infiltrée dans les poumons peut
provoquer une infection et vous tuer
plusieurs jours après on appelle ça une
seconde noyade malgré tous ces risques
elle les apnéistes s'obstine à repousser
leurs limites toujours plus longtemps
toujours plus profond toujours plus
risqués il y a à peine 60 ans les
scientifiques estimé que le corps humain
ne pouvait pas résister à une profondeur
de plus de 40 mètres pourtant en 2007
herbert nitsch un gros fou malade qui
détient 33 records du monde réalise une
descente en une seule inspiration à 214
m plus de deux fois la longueur d'un
terrain de foot même les plantes ne
pousse plus dans cet environnement
hostile pour atteindre une telle
profondeur nietzsche s'attache
préalablement à un poids qu'ils entrent
vers le fond et quand il veut remonter
il ouvre une bouteille qui va gonfler un
ballon avec lequel il va se laisser
tracter jusqu'à la surface on appelle ça
de l'apnée nos limites avant lui
seulement 4 apnéistes avait dépassé la
barre des 170 m et hélas deux d'entre
eux étaient morts à la remontée devant
la multiplication du nombre d'accidents
le guinness des records et les
fédérations d'apnée refusent maintenant
d'homologuer ce type de record quelle
est la profondeur maximale avec
bouteilles de plongée en septembre 2014
ahmed cabré à valider un record mondial
de plongée à la bouteille
332 m c'est comme descendre la tour
eiffel mais cette fois sous l'eau la
pression est telle que même un sous
marin de la seconde guerre mondiale il y
aurait été complètement broyé autant
dire que le bonhomme était sacrément
stock ex majeur de combat des forces
spéciales égyptiennes instructeur de
plongée pendant 17 ans une préparation
physique de quatre ans waouh avec
beaucoup de courage et un peu
d'inconscience ce jour là après 12
minutes de descente il aura réussi son
défi non sans quelques dommages
physiques mais attends 332 mètres c'est
bien non mais le record de plongée en
apnée et 2 214 m alors que lui il triche
un peu avec ses bouteilles d'oxygène ça
lui permet théoriquement de tenir des
heures du coup qu'est ce qui l'a arrêté
en fait une bouteille de plongée c'est
pas forcément la meilleure des choses en
apnée les bouteilles sont deux gros
problèmes
d'abord l'état des poumons parce qu à
332 mètres l'eau exerce sur vous une
pression de 35 tonnes par mètre carré
c'est comme s'ils ne semi-remorque que
vous écrasez les côtes impossible dans
ces conditions de gonfler ses poumons
pour aspirer de l'eire 1-1 ap nice n'a
pas besoin de ça un plongeur 6 pour y
arriver il va devoir respirer de l'air
mise à très haute pression pour forcer
un passage dans ses poumons mais
attention deuxième problème l'air peut
devenir un poison celui qu'on respire
est composé d'un tiers dioxygène ça on
en a besoin pour survivre et de deux
tiers de diazote un gaz qui d'habitude
n'affecte pas notre corps mais si un
plongeur respire cette terre normal
haute pression le diazote va forcer son
chemin dans les poumons et réussi à
entrer dans le sang on appelle ça la
narcose à la zot ou l'ivresse des
profondeurs et elle porte bien son nom
après une intoxication à la zot on
observe les mêmes effets que si le
plongeur était bourré tous les 15 mètres
c'est comme s'ils vivaient un shot de
vodka il va commencer par être hilare et
halluciné oublier les gestes les plus
élémentaires devenir complètement
incohérent mélanger l'eau et le pas
débrancher son propre équipement puis
sombré dans le coma
ce genre de tragédie a par exemple eu
lieu dans le benchmark rôle 283 mètres
de profondeur le plongeur die show a
voulu faire une bonne action en allant
chercher le corps d'un jeune homme resté
au fond pendant plus de dix ans mais ce
qui va se passer durant sa descente est
un véritable enfer si vous souhaitez
connaître la fin je vous invite à aller
regarder notre vidéo sur la chaîne trash
qui en parle je vous mettrai le lien en
fin de vidéo pour éviter l'effet bourg
et on remplace une partie du dialogue
par un autre gaz par exemple l'hélium
qui a un effet moins prononcée sur le
corps mais ça résout pas totalement
problème car la pression modifie aussi
la chimie de l'oxygène dans ces
conditions extrêmes elle devient un
dangereux neurotoxiques et là pas moyen
de la remplacer un troisième problème
est survenu pour ahmed garbrah l'effet
ventouse c'est tout bête mais c'est à
cause de ton masque de plongée il ya une
différence de pression entre l'intérieur
et l'extérieur
le résultat l'appel d'air dont masque va
s'amplifier comme si on y brancher un
aspirateur de plus en plus puissants et
avec ça c'est vos yeux qui vont prendre
cher 1 des accidents de plongée les plus
terrifiants s'appelle le squeeze on le
voyait surtout à l'époque ont plongé
avec des scaphandres pied lourd imagine
toi avec ce gros truc tu tribu dans un
trou la pression ne va pas avoir le
temps de s'équilibrer ton crâne été
tirées de tous les côtés et splatch
juste de cauchemardesque ok revenons-en
à mes 12 deux descentes 332 mètres et un
corps soumis à des effets bien
désagréable mais c'était pas ça le pire
dans son record savez vous combien de
bouteilles il lui a fallu pour cette
plongée une pour descendre et une pour
remonter vous me direz non 60 60
bouteilles accrochées le long du chemin
tout avec un mélange d'airs spécifique
dosé par des médecins le mec est donc
dans le noir complet écrasée de partout
et il doit attendre comme ça en croisant
les doigts pour que l'air qui le
maintient en vie ne soit pas en fait en
train de le tuer sachant qu'au moindre
pépin personne ne peut venir l'aider
heureusement qu'il était complètement
bourré pour supporter tout ça et c'est
une fois au fond que le plus pénible
doit commencer remontée conscient pour
que le record soit validé et ça lui a
pris 12 heures la raison vous avez
sûrement déjà entendu parler des paliers
de décompression
ce sont des pauses que le plongeur doit
faire à la remontée pour que le gaz dans
ses veines s'évacue lentement si vous ne
les respectez pas imaginer que vous êtes
une bouteille de coca qu'on a bien
secoué si on ouvre d'un coup la pression
se libère brutalement et c'était un
geyser de bulles dans votre sens je vous
laisse imaginer les conséquences même si
ces bulles sont tout petit et qu'il ne
semble pas y avoir eu d'accident elles
peuvent s'accumuler ou fil des plongées
et nécrosés certains organes c'est
justement à cause de ces petites bulles
qu'il ne faut pas prendre l'avion le
lendemain d'une plongée pour calculer
quand ils doivent faire des pauses les
plongeurs peuvent utiliser un petit
ordinateur mais à de telles profondeurs
les scientifiques ignorent comment le
corps réagit voilà pourquoi il est
difficile d'estimer le record
infranchissable de plonger à la
bouteille et vous juste que pour le
commun des mortels à partir de 200 m
vous êtes déjà en morse ou sursis quelle
est la profondeur maximale avec un sous
marin avec tous ces problèmes ça paraît
difficile de rester longtemps en
profondeur c'est un des gros problèmes
pour les plates-formes pétrolières
t'envoie un plongeur pour réparer un
problème ça lui prend une minute de
resserrer les boulons et là tu doit le
payer
there as rien faire pour sa remontée
feignasses va une entreprise française a
trouvé la solution on n'a qu'à les
laisser en profondeur avec une capsule
bien sûr dans laquelle ils vont habiter
plusieurs mois en s'habituant aux
pressions extrêmes mais constante un
petit plouf et ils sont directs au fond
pour resserrer les boulons les journées
de boulot doivent quand même être un peu
spécial en plus d'être à moitié ivre à
cause de l'hélium tes collègues parlent
avec une sorte de voix d'enfant
ils doivent se taper des sacrés bar
quand même un gros avantage c'est que la
cloche de plongée peut être remonter
rapidement à la surface jus qu'on garde
tout sous haute pression un peu de
lumière du jour un petit coucou et on
les déplace sur un autre spot de travail
c'est tellement pratique que l'armée
utilise ça pour secourir les sous-marins
naufragés une fois le job tu es la
décompression se fait hors de l'eau de
façon lente et safe pendant plusieurs
jours car s'ils ont rééquilibré la
pression d'un coup tous les vaisseaux
sanguins des plongeurs exploserait le
record de profondeur dans ses caisses
sont pressurisés et 2 700 mètres c'était
un labo à la surface qui recréer les
conditions extrêmes des profondeurs dans
lequel ce mec passé 43 jours rien que
pour revenir à la pression normale sept
ans m c'est bien mais les abysses sont
encore loin la fosse mariannes ses onze
mille mètres de profondeur un everest
d'eau la pression y est mille fois plus
forte qu'à l'air libre dix mille tonnes
d'eau au m² tout le poids de la tour
eiffel sur ton thorax du coup les
entrailles de l'océan resteront-ils a
jamais inatteignable à l'homme en
plongée carrément ya pas moyen de
résister à ça par contre la technologie
elle sait le faire ou presque il existe
une classe spéciale de sous-marins conçu
pour résister à ces pressions
destructrice ce sont les bathyscaphe et
ils ont été inventés par celui qui a
inspiré le personnage du professeur
tournesol auguste piccard ces engins
sont généralement des petites sphères
pour répartir la pression équitablement
sur les parois en revanche ils ne
peuvent se déplacer que verticalement
ils ont donc besoin d'un bateau et de
toute une équipe à la surface pour les
récupérer mais comme beaucoup de choses
peuvent mal se passer un système de
sécurité très stylé est prévu grâce à
des électroaimants le bathyscaphe
transporte celui des billes de métal si
un accident venait à couper le courant
cela désactiverait les électro aimants
lâchant le lest et le bathyscaphe
remonterait flotter à la surface avec
des submersibles de cette trempe il
devient possible d'atteindre les points
les plus profondes de l'océan vous vous
souvenez de la fosse des mariannes et de
ses 11 km de profondeur le bathyscaphe
ios ce triste a atteint 10 1916 m le 23
janvier 1960 et depuis le temps on n'a
pas fait beaucoup mieux 12 mètres
seulement de plus en 2019 par victor
vescovo c'est tellement risqué est cher
que très peu de monde s'y aventurent
jugez par vous même nous avons été douze
fois sur la lune alors que trois
missions seulement ont atteint les
abysses de l'océan dans sa descente on a
découvert des merveilles il neige marine
ininterrompue constitué de plancton et
des détritus marin produit par des
kilomètres de vie aquatique au dessus de
notre tête cette nourriture tombé du
ciel permet à toute une faune abyssal de
survivre dans ce lieu pourtant hostile
on a pu identifier plus de 40 nouvelles
espèces mais ils ont également fait une
nouvelle découverte qui fait froid dans
le dos sur le plancher océanique dans le
noir absolu des abysses ils ont
découvert des traces de civilisation
humaine la nôtre des déchets plastiques
tombé au fond de l'océan la isolé de
tout il ne se décompose quasiment pas et
dans des milliers d'années l'ultime
trace de notre passage sur terre sera
peut-être une décharge de détritus
plastiques au fond des abysses notre
héritage sur cette planète